hello everyone my name is Mario Gonzalez
I'm a senior applications developer at
Ogilvy & Mather in New York and I'm
gonna be talking about real time
multiplayer games with nodejs for the
Ogilvie's 2011 holiday card we decided
to make an html5 game and having heard a
lot about nodejs and socket IO slightly
we decided that we should create a
multiplayer game the game is currently
located at hall of the Holliday 2010
dal-gu be calm and I'm going to briefly
just try to play it and see how it looks
and let's see how that goes so so this
is the game I'm gonna just jump in
select a character that guy's fine and
then I'm gonna open up a new tab and do
the same thing give me one second in
here oh there you go somebody else is
playing right now so so this is an
example of a game that we created the
game runs on canvas and then the
multiplayer engine is created using
node.js and WebSockets on the browser
side so I'm going to talk a little bit
about how we went about creating this
game some problems that we faced and a
framework that we created recently which
abstracted the difficult networking
stuff out of this game and we've
released it onto github earlier this
week and goodbye
so the benefits of writing your game
with JavaScript and nodejs one of them
is that javascript is actually a really
great language for writing games has all
of the tools that you need in order to
write a game concisely and you can play
around with a lot of different things
because you're not held back by
allocating of allocation of memory and
you don't have to worry about the stack
versus the heap nodejs and v8 are
extremely fast in our game the node
process was using only one thread and it
runs out about three to four CPU usage
while running eight simultaneous games
each with their own collision collision
engine instance because decline in the
server are both running in JavaScript
you get a great interoperability between
the client and the server there's no
translation layer that you need to apply
because the the world state existed in
some sort of data on the server side and
existing and different data on the
supplied side and you need to translate
that when they communicate with each
other and an example this is for example
if you have a vector math utility class
you can just outright use that class in
both sides of the game this is an
example of the interoperability between
the client and the server this is this
represents the net channel message class
which actually is just a value object
that contains some data but we didn't
have to write anything to turn that into
something the server understands and
then turn it back to the what the client
understands it's all JavaScript so
that's pretty cool that's right a game
we had a couple of problems that arose
but the one that I'm gonna be talking
about today is the problem that we face
that's faced by all real-time
multiplayer games and that is dealing
with latency the initial naive approach
is to package up the clients information
and then send that to the server and
then the server will send that same
message off to all of the other clients
and that works fine in a system where
you have trusted clients such as a
military simulation but in a real game
on the Internet
that approach starts to break down and
the reason why is that the main problem
with this approach is that we can no we
cannot trust users to provide us with
correct and from
about their players current state if you
ask a nefarious user and he enters a
game where his projectile is he'll tell
you it's everywhere and what his health
is is always number dot max value so
simple workaround is to store the state
on the server and play the game
simultaneously on a server as well as
playing it locally the problem with that
is that the players local position as
shown on the left side circle and then
the players blue position is where the
player is actually located and as you
can see your projectile on your screen
will appear to have hit this player but
it will go right through them because
I'm a server that players no longer at
that position this is actually obviously
a very large problem because it happens
in Reverse you might be moving and then
a projectile will kill you and you
clearly dodged it but it's because what
you see on your local version of the
game does not match what is going on on
a server right now another problem with
this approach is sometimes referred to
as the bouncing ball problem and that is
that if as we receive new position and
new information regarding the velocity
of the entity from the server we draw
that entity with this information and it
causes abrupt shifts in motion along the
project the projectiles path in this
chart the dotted lines represent
discrete information received from the
server at regular intervals and if we
draw the players path using the
instantaneous velocity at that given
point the path takes very abrupt sharp
edges and it's incorrect and incorrect
until it receives new more up-to-date
information at which point that red line
will now move along that path at that
velocity and will continue to be
incorrect and incorrect and then switch
again when it receives new information
and you get a very zigzag style motion
that appears on a screen the blue line
represents the player's actual movement
see of course this time is measured in
milliseconds so a common solution is to
decrease the sampling rate on the server
side so that players send receive more
information about their world state and
that same chart will happen again but it
happens that such small incremental
spaces that it's hard to visually notice
the problem this is only an even more
naive solution because most of the time
you cannot have that kind of message
throughput to all clients at all times
unless they're all on OC threes so we
took a different approach this is
actually quite common approach in
multiplayer games like on consoles or
the source engine comes to mind
originally it came from quake world and
so I decided to look around and see how
other people have been doing this
because creating multiplayer games real
time multiplayer games has been being
done for a while and I found some
interesting information
the quake world source code is open
source along with several the other
quake games and valve also has some
white papers regarding networking in
real time games and in this approach the
single authoritative server is prospered
this represents one tick on the client
side and server side in this approach
this prop the server will process inputs
move the objects update the game
simulation create a single snapshot and
then let its server than a channel do
what it needs to do I'll explain what
that means later on the client-side it's
actually only responsible for two things
one of them is to sample the user
intervals at a discreet rate and then
render the world the benefit of this
approach is that you can have a really
really really interesting game and
because all of that logic and all in the
entire simulation happens on the server
you can really go apeshit with if with
what your game can do you can have
physics on top of other things and
various things and every single browser
that's playing the game sees the same
thing regardless of whether their
browser can keep up a two-dimensional
rigid body physics simulation and
display a canvas element with 100
objects it doesn't matter because
they're only in charge of displaying the
object
and everyone's simulation also MAGIX it
kind of lines up our nervous system is
designed to work around latency we're
very good at that so if we can apply a
smooth content constant latin c to an
object's path human beings can adjust to
that very well
so the key piece of the puzzle where I
sort of started to have the Eureka
moment of this as I was going through
the valve source papers is that we
actually simply render all the clients
and milliseconds in the past so I'm just
gonna call that number 75 but it's just
an arbitrary number and and that's what
this is the current time
on the current time on the client side
is shown over here so we can say that
the current time is about ten point four
six seconds now we render the world at
ten point three two seconds those
triangles represent world snapshots that
we've received from a server so the
first thing that we do is we find the
value for the rendering time which is
the current time minus some number then
after that we loop through the existing
world snapshot updates that we have from
the server and we find two that we fall
in between and now that we have found
those two world snapshots using a simple
linear interpolation function we can
precisely place our object at its
position along that path another benefit
to this approach is that if one of those
packets were dropped for example if we
did not have packet 3 for two we could
still interpolate between packets three
for one and three for three
and the user will end up in their
correct location so it's actually a
pretty good protector against packet
loss and it actually assumes that
packets will be lost and the system can
bounce back from that so we decided that
this was a pretty interesting idea and
some of these concepts would help
JavaScript game developers so we
abstracted these concepts from our game
and we created a framework for them and
I'm gonna show you a demo now all right
so see
I'm gonna start the server and then open
up my browser and see
all right there we go
so this besides being pretty is actually
running is a hold on I cannot see my
screen this will have to do okay so this
actual simulation is running on the
server where's my little character
that's me as I'm moving around mice
keyboard those entities are being
controlled on the server so I'm gonna
try I'm having a little bit of computer
problems here but I'm gonna try to open
up this in a different tab so here we
have synchronized multiplayer activity
going on and see if I can make this guy
show up there and in the other large
circle is somewhere else on the screen I
can't really find them so the way that
the engine works is that everything that
you're seeing is actually happening on
the server and the server simply sends
world snapshots to all of the clients so
everyone is guaranteed to be in sync at
the same time it doesn't it does add a
little bit of latency towards your
movement by default because you're
always rendering and milliseconds back
in time but human beings are very good
at adapting to that it's better to
render a little bit behind in time and
adjust to that lag than it is to
constantly have abrupt changes in motion
and then the other benefit is because it
is running on the server and this is a
little bit of a cooler demo we can show
if I can find a house where's my mouse
okay
because it is running on the server I'm
going to fire up the other demo that I
have which is actually a box 2d
implementation that was ported to
JavaScript and it's actually really well
done and I'm gonna try to time these
because it looks really really cool in
the beginning so let's see if I can pull
that off
I didn't pull that off I can't sorry and
I can't find my mouse there you go
all right let's try it one more time I'm
just gonna drag this like this there you
go so this is an example of a box 2d
simulation that is being run on the
server and the clients are being told
where these objects are and they are
interpolating between any of the two
positions and this helps you get really
fluid motion the cool thing about that
is that I'm gonna join or try to join
with a different browser so here's an
instance of Firefox and I'm going to
join the same I'm gonna join this game
and now we have synchronized physics
across two different browser instances
that are playing the same game and it's
actually running at a pretty good
framerate in Firefox and pretty much the
same frame rate in Chrome and the
simulation is running on my computer and
nodejs
but I'm gonna also try to see if I can
get Safari to do this three browsers
might be a little bit too much for my
computer but we can give it a try there
you go so now we have all three main
modern browsers running the same physics
simulation there we go
cool thing is so here's some interaction
between I'm sending my information to
the server and then it's playing the
game I think my computer is kind of
gonna mess it up a little bit and then
that's just a demo of the box for the
implementation that is built in the
library
No
and then the last thing I'm sure I don't
know if I'm over on time but I wanted to
show that the small amount of code that
it takes to get something like that up
and running so for this for this demo I
have a I can never seem to find my mouse
on here so ignoring the framework I'm
going to show just these few files that
I have and basically the demo app is
just a namespace then I have some file
that has a couple of constants in there
for me so the main two points of entry
for using this library are the demo
client game which is what is the browser
will be this will display and a demo
server game this is where all your cool
stuff goes so the demo client game
doesn't really have too much to it it
has a set up view function real time
multiplayer nodejs is agnostic to
whatever view you would like to use so
it could be canvas or something else it
has a simple tick function which gets
called and it has this function which
once the engine detects a new entity it
will tell you hey create an entity from
this description that description has
some properties that are passed to it
from the server and then you can have
some callbacks for when connection
happens when it disconnects you don't
actually have to do anything with these
at this point and then the server game
all that's going on here is I create a
new instance of the collision manager
this is just actually a very simple
radius based collision manager that I
created that does provide group masking
so that for example my projectiles don't
hit anyone elses on my team's
projectiles so it initializes that
creates a few entities and then calls
tick and then these are the callbacks
for the network so that's about it and
that that that amount of code will get
you running with the first demo the
box2d demo has a little bit more things
in it but they're all related to box 2d
and this framework is live on github as
of a few days ago
so I work for Ogilvy that's it thank you